for another stream should make sure I
don't have the same mic issues as
earlier my phone is across the room so
hopefully it's okay I just had to
challenge but it disappeared oh it's
back okay I'm gonna play this guy he's
rated under a thousand my connections
okay
seems to be lagging
yeah there's a pretty big rating
differential but hopefully this will be
entertaining or slightly instructive see
how he plays just started playing chess
watching my Vince a good luck have fun
I'll go for a Ponzi on E
if he he plays knight c6 see what he's
got
b6 what is b6 novelty might be a novelty
gonna play d4 hello to people in the
chat
hello Braden hello Nathan and hello ref
Raqqah
oh man ok I'm gonna go for the kill
relatively early I try like stuff like
this b5
all that that's attempting to disturb my
plans I'm going to put the bishop on d5
if I still wanna play Queen b3
let's see if he sees that I'm attacking
his night hopefully he plays 97
hmm so I wanted to meet him
okay I'm just gonna play normal moose
let's show some respect in a castle
I'm the wait 497 and just please play 97
yes okay hello to more people in the
chat hello last shot Jane hello the
ancient gamer yes
I've changed the title to don't
challenge me because yesterday I had the
title as challenged me I got too many
challenges and I was slowing everything
down so hopefully now people will not
challenge me and maybe it will be
manageable acer baits with the cheer two
days in a row with a cheer appreciate
that
um who's challenging me
we'll play Adam good look at them
some reason it's lagging like before a
game starts maybe it's just because of
the server
I have ping my ping is pretty good 45
milliseconds hello to more people
Katsura ydx VCT uh we have a London
now I have to think what do I play in
some London
I want to do something new okay I saw
something today actually I'm gonna try a
different line it's gonna start out for
you very normally and then we're gonna
see how it goes I guess I can start with
e six
karma with a hundred bits Thank You car
Mar I'll open up stream labs I'm gonna
start with this
so the line I actually discovered today
occurred in one of my students games my
student was white he was playing the
London he got this position and his
opponent played c5 which is still normal
White's going to play see three wonder
if Adam is watching maybe Adams watching
that's okay um and then my students
opponent played Queen c7
which normally isn't playable cuz black
commits the knight to c6 so early
like if the knight we're on c6 and black
loses upon do 2d takes e5 but here the
Queen on c7 is perfectly fine and the
plan is to play 97 in Pawnee five
I was looking briefly at this about two
hours ago
and I was trying to find a way for a
white to keep some advantage but it
seems tricky
actually seems really like direct for
black this might just equalize the
entire London opening Bishop d3 okay
Knight pd7
maybe 95 is possible for a white button
still 97 okay
play I put you 5 remember castle first
because now white can't playing that e5
and maybe I can even prepare it further
with rookie and e5
hello the Capablanca hello crunchy rap
more people
the Lord on anonymous toilet noggin 99
interesting name made a stream and you
subbed thanks for the sub tiling again
you appreciate that
I still want to play e5 ooh takes but I
take back
b5 will grab the whole center
wait a minute the synced to audio and
video my computer's just being slow
I was about to play e5 but does that
lose upon tonight c4
so tricky
2594
I can play queen a six toilet noggin
with a hundred bits so generous
such a new viewer next toilet noggin
okay now I'm just preventing him
rucastle we might get some like
queenless middle game after Queenie - we
could trade Queens and then Braden will
be excited
if he doesn't play Queenie - maybe I'll
play in 93 or maybe I'll just play like
rookie 85
there's ideas there are ideas I should
say
I've been watching on YouTube for ages
Wow
are you also toilet noggin on YouTube I
don't recognize that name
okay we're going to get a queen this
middle game and play b6 now I want my
bishop to come to a6
I think black is slightly better but
it's not anything huge but its pleasant
this king is gonna have to I don't know
what his King is going to do
have to go back to e 1 or D 1
I can't art target f2
wait a minute I'm just winning f2 King
d1 Knight g4 and f2 can't be defended
it's so nice unless he wants to play c4
it but that would lose upon
well what happens when pieces come to
get squares
I wasn't expecting the advantage to be
so so quick they're so big so quickly
that's nice
what's the point of giving out the Queen
I'm not sure exactly what that means
um do you mean what's the point of
trading Queens I traded Queens cuz my
queen was a bit awkward on a six what
else do I do here I could move my queen
again but then lightly castle I traded
Queens to get my Bishop to a6 and target
his King and now life is good
oh you just don't count it on YouTube
but you watch okay that's nice I'm going
to take on f2 I'm gonna threaten 93
initiative keeps coming yes to play does
you have to play king b1
and then probably still 93
up upon it position
I don't have to play 93 immediately I'm
gonna play rook c8 this 93 can come any
time I just want him to think as if I
were to play 93 he would just take and
he wouldn't have to think um can you
challenge me you can challenge me if you
want even though the stream title says
don't challenge me but it might be that
might be some reverse psychology
let's play 93 and maybe he'll think a
lot of things are attacked
if you'll take and then I'll take back
or he won't take
everything's defended keep improving
yeah I'm pretty happy here oh and this
is casual too okay no rating points on
the line
hello to more people hello excise sparks
hello were cool level 100 tick with
Knights
I didn't see the challenge I'm not done
watching the YouTube video which YouTube
video
is it the one is it the stream that I
did last night because that's archived
on Twitch too
I'm
to find the balance on YouTube between
uploading streams and uploading like
exclusive content for YouTube
I'm not sure
sure what the balance should be
he wants to play rock h4 I just want to
expand the center I'm gonna play f6
restricting the Knights preparing e5 we
plays rook age 4 then I play g6
this rook is so sad
and this time is pretty sad too
could have played b6 and so did queen
tikki - maybe that was possible it may
have led to something very similar
we take stakes as king is still stuck in
the center
I honestly didn't consider b6
you
okay Center is nice maybe I'll play 94
soon
if he takes I open the D file if he
doesn't take C 3s following
you
[Music]
yeah this is looking really good
mmm check the pond
six is hanging I should have given him
f6 it's okay
will he take it
question he doesn't take it Wow
okay
while this is nice well someone subbed
great and subbed gifted by Nathan thanks
Nathan
and thanks Adam for the free rook so
generous
okay um yeah honestly this was probably
just another viewer challenge stream so
if you want to challenge me you're
you're allowed to but then you're just
not paying attention to the title fake
news what's fake news woke up at 8 a.m.
if the London was suddenly refuted I'm
pretty sure I for a few to the London
with this game oh yeah good game thank
you
yeah like this is so simple but I think
it's I don't know I'll have to do my
research I was looking up some line
earlier
was it it was some weird move order
where white doesn't play Knight f3 but
plays this
Knight Bishop d6
and without the nine of F three I think
there's some weird things like Y could
play F for like maybe this is a
potential way to meet this Queen C 797
setup is to play F for and either 395
but then you have to be paying attention
earlier to not commit the night too
early to F 3 in some cases
you
box scores well anyway um what's your
definition of the miniature I think
miniature is usually a game that's
twenty-five moves or less I might be
mistaken but that's my definition hello
to mxp pH
hello to more people okay we'll do
another game r.i.p IM jus tang what
happened to end your tang
I start another game we're gonna watch
some us junior tournaments
oh and thank you for the follow PM PDM
dev preciate that um yeah I'm gonna
quickly glance at the juniors we'll just
look at Andrew tang cuz it might be a
London is he white he's playing the
London rights
oh no he's playing the Tori wow what a
shocker
and you tame I think this is some theory
I wouldn't be surprised actually if
Andrew is getting some help from John
Bartholomew just because they're both
internet chests celebrities and John
also plays the Tori and they're both
from Minnesota but I honestly I don't
know who Andrews working with that looks
like an interesting variation go forward
to the current position they played a
lot of moose Brooke take f7 wait once
thanks for the follow great serve Yuri
this is a mover take f7 what if King to
f7
back is upper rook
you
I'm not seeing it the immediate points
oh he's down a piece wait he sacked a
piece he sacked a piece this night was
lost and then he sacked a rook oh so I
guess the point is okay he's attacking
the Queen what is going on here this is
a current position what was a problem
with King take F seven
oh the rook is hanging on seats
but then black would just be up to minor
pieces
missing something really obvious no
one's really helping out in the chats
Thank You campus for the follow
come
crows how good is he are you talking
about me or Andrew
I mean Andrews approach
I'm so confused about this position this
position is against my style this is
just too chaotic
what would the move for white be Oh
[ __ ] up g6 or Bishop e6 maybe Bishop e6
forgot after king so the King can't
moved to the e-file if the King moves to
f6 or d5 I assume that's good for
were white and if King f8
I thought is very reasonable there's
queen a3 or queen bee florida this is
probably the idea
as Queenie seven runs into 96 and I
assume King eh run into the very least
bishop taxi it
okay this would be interesting I'm gonna
accept someone
uh we could play let's play the only
patron who is challenging me
using me to a correspondence we're gonna
play boomer 34
lock boomer 34
us
over 268 classical games interesting
hello stump arena sounds like a new name
okay I'm gonna play some normal stuff
maybe I will take opening suggestions if
people want to see a specific line
against d4 let me know
Kings Indian Greenfeld Slav sunny Slav
ugd drew Samson thanks for the sub Tier
three sub is that weight is at the
highest possible sub
there's that no that's Tier one
normally get confused no that's I think
that's my first ever tier 3 subscriber
thank you drew Wow and you got access to
some some emotes umm so generous
like the Scotch candid it's hard to play
the Scotch gambit against d4 it's also
hard to play the leningrad dutch after
fighting died f6
play the Alekhine semi Slav says exei
sparks okay we're gonna play a semi Slav
well play b5 right now I miss that I was
scrolling up so I was looking at the
most recent lease reasons
you
ah okay
uh-huh good luck yeah we're gonna play a
semi-soft so he's not watching the
stream so I can be as as revealing as
possible with my inner thoughts and this
is dedicated to X I sparks who suggested
something that I can actually play
um one fun fact actually just to satisfy
Nathan or to instruct Nathan if okay let
me just play that next move if black
play is b5 in this position I think the
strongest move for white is to play e4
I'm pretty sure there's an Aronian
Carlsen game Aronian was White's he knew
to play e4 and I take e4 bishop take b5
I think White's just better there are
like clear advantage for lights anyway
I'm playing something a bit more
standard I'm playing this a 6m e Slav
which is used I think was used by gal
fans against Anand and their World
Championship match
it's a bit sad that
like they played against each other in
World Championship and now not even in
the candidates okay Bishop d3 this is a
whole point of Asics is after taking I
play b5 and then c5
allow
please reveal my inner thoughts that's
what I'm doing these are my inner
thoughts
okay be five and a six is a useful move
because it defends b5 and enable c5 in
one one tempo not a placeholder thanks
for following
and mmm cone noth or as a Coonan neuf
not sure how to pronounce that but
thanks for the follow also Franco seein
things for the follow
you
okay so he's thinking it's good sign
see five still in prep honestly I'm a
bit out of prep after c5 but I know the
general setup of just developing
castling usually the Queen comes to b6
rooks come to the center
and then White has to figure out how to
develop this bishop most cases white
will at some point take on c5 and then
play b3 but should be too
and we'll see what he does how often
does twitch ask for the Danish
not too often
any of my viewers requests Danish
a scotch is a bit more common like
scotch
Kings Indians sometimes
London opening honk loud Rob all the
weird stuff I'm gonna play Bishop d7 I'm
waiting for him to take on c5 so I can
develop my bishop in one move if I were
to play Bishop e7 then he takes I
essentially lose a tempo so I'm gonna
hold off as long as possible to develop
my bishop unless he takes
and maybe I could even consider taking
on d4 we'll see
when did I start to play chess when I
was seven I learned the game I got into
it really quickly
using some reverse psychology with the
title yeah it's not not my intention to
use reverse psychology I'm just trying
to use psychology
maybe people are being affected by
reverse psychology I don't know I should
try the hippo good try the hippo
that's an opening
so what does he want to do maybe he
wants to play e4 you can play e4 right
away because I would play b4 and then
the pawn
or
I could consider taking
I want to play 97
74 I should mention that like if you
were to play e4 I take take I can't take
on d4 because Bishop take me five wins
the Queen
so I'm looking at the sea for when I
take e five
pawn can advance quickly so maybe I
should just take if he takes on my play
Bishop e7 he takes with Knights I play
Bishop d6
I open this Bishop have to think a bit
carefully
maybe I'm just trying to ask for
much
I also have a move here Knight to c6
couraging efore cos d4 is a is pressured
I'm gonna play 96
I didn't consider that move right away
because if boxa bishop and normally the
knight goes to d7 but i think it's a
reasonable move because d4 is the focal
points
answers idea and now we'll think
why not push the pawn to c5 my partners
on c5 I'm guessing you mean why not push
the pawn to c4 that's a move if I play
c4 the problem is it relieves all the
pressure on his center and he would play
a move maybe like Bishop to b1 and then
more easily advance so I want to keep
the tension I just don't want to give
him like a big pawn Center
axe villager is here axe villager mists
uh we missed you in last night's stream
not entirely sure man
wait what's
how long have you been streaming on
Twitch
I've been streaming for I started
regularly back in October so it's not a
full year yet but recently it's been
irregular just because I'm traveling so
much and I was playing two tournaments
but now it's probably going to be a few
times a week
when you go to Subway what kind of sub
do you get I I'd like to get the sub of
the day cause it's just Friday and I
don't like making decisions and the sub
of the day is always cheaper anyway so
but if I'm in a rush I get the cold cut
combo because it's cold and it's a condo
how is the Blitz tournament I didn't
play the Blitz tournament as I was tired
and I would have had to wake up at 6
a.m. and I'm a little bit sick know if
it's allergies or what's I'm playing I'm
definitely playing a tournament on
Friday it's going to be like some
variance
DJ and thanks for the follow I will play
Bishop e7
not the most exciting structure pretty
symmetrical but I like the fact that
this bishop is still undeveloped if he
takes takes and it's very hard to
develop the dark squared bishop splasher
thanks for the follow and daro Yves
thanks for the follow
a three keeping the tension
what to do
B he wants to play P for most likely
and then Bishop b2
considering Queen g5 here Queen d5 ideas
of rook t8 also hitting the Knights
play Knight c3 I could play Queen h5
- its
looks interesting
I usually play a bit longer games this
is quick for me aha still new to chess
yeah I can see he plays a lot of
classical chess
uhh
but okay that's
I mean he could have challenged me to a
longer time control
Oh
well I'm not giving you more time
so manage it well
yeah that's one thing I don't do to to
people is give them more time
someone did that to me yesterday was it
it was I'm singer and I still lost
Lukas fiber thanks for the follow
yeah Nathan Scott sharing the schedule
command I only have a set schedule yet I
should probably add the UM the leech s
titled arena number six because I had
just announced it today
I believe it's planned for August August
4th I think you just fine a night
this hangar nights
you hunger nights what's so sad maybe
now I can give you a hard time
oh if I click this it just Auto adds
time
you
I'm not giving you more time
opening periods of 59
hello my her 0-9
I'm behind with comments
something about IHSA sorry I'm missing a
lot of comments here I'll try and
respond
is on vacation and I was bad okay no
worries
um
I'm also hunt vacation but then that is
good so unless complaints did you manage
to make it to IHS a States this year
yeah I've been coming to IHS a state for
the last like nine years in a row since
2009
um somehow it just always works out to
stop by because it's between st. Louis
and Chicago
oh you were assistant coach you
graduated in 2013 so maybe we we
probably cross paths at some points by
losing a no I'm not losing a piece I've
repeat
um but I would like something more I
play this
and Bishop take okay
you
I'm looking for fancy moves here
normal move
Burke pH should be good enough
you
someday I'm gonna make use of this
diagonal and it'll be nice some way
somehow
might have to start with some improving
moves would probably want to play rook
d8 which almost traps a queen like you
would have to play Queen c7
and then what to do
it's a bit awkward I could play Bishop
f6
about double pawns
I just want to trade pieces I also want
to open the G file is then there's ideas
of this G choose of long-term targets if
he takes on f6 and I take then there's
ideas of 95
okay I'm happy
there are any streaming schedules yeah
I'm probably not going to have a
schedule for this week just because it's
hard to predict the future once I get a
more normal routine I'll probably put
together a schedule
yeah you miss I HSHS that was fun I mean
if you're in college there's collegiate
chess
pan ends own bow things for the follow
you know if the USCF candidate master
can participate in me chest titled arena
is USCF even give away the CM title I'm
curious
okay real quick new page I am Rosen
I'm just gonna go to my page and see if
I've ever won the Canada past your title
from US chess oh this is gonna end
pretty brutally for lights
but is night is my take T for the best
mover is 95 of the best move I'm just
going to take this he's going to take
back right
oh he sees it maybe he sees it
does Lee chest give the CM title I don't
think I've seen the CM on me Ches
Riz lam 13 thanks for the follow no oh
he saw it
well now I'm up to pieces but my Queens
attacked and my Knights attacked
take on that three
and then
yeah this is probably just winning
um
where is it the rating no it's more
you
it used to be a page where you see all
the titles you get
hey here it is hey candidate master
title I got in 2009
um
be they title or nm
interesting
I assume fee title is a FMR better
I have not seen the Colorado gambits
what is that
remember when you guys set up the boards
and played silo with my coal yeah I do
remember that that was uh that was
actually featured on like some local
news segment it was so random I do
remember that
I'm really behind in the chat my college
doesn't have competing chess team you
should start a chess team if they don't
have one
the Chess Club oh it's you're president
of
um really you just need to find three
other players who would be interested in
taking a trip to Pan Am's I'm not sure
which city it is but I would talk to the
school about getting funding most
schools have like funding rights for
teams
I'm a play king each it's like when I
study that University of Illinois it was
all student Ron all students like we had
to find part of the trip but University
gave us some money we had to apply for
it so it's possible if you put in
efforts I would think
oh we just does show cm
interesting Colorado is efore knight c6
9 f3 f5 I've never seen that
maybe it's playable though good game
boomer 34
Thanks next time feel free to challenge
me to a longer time control if you like
I'm saying that because I feel like
there is a pretty high demand or pretty
high high amount of requests for
classical chess over it let's our bullet
so if people want to challenge me to
standard or rapid I'm I'm becoming more
inclined to accept those types of
challenges
and I I do apologize there's just so
many comments I can't respond to
everyone all respond to what I can okay
let's accept mine accept another
challenge
alpha0 wizard I don't play
correspondence that's one thing I almost
never accept
I don't know I would I'm just gonna
accept the other patron
guess it's a benefit to being a patron
on me chess
ADHD
avid competitive or is it ADH david
competitive we'll never know
good luck I'm not just the screen this
is really plugging me there's a just a
little bit of yeah there we go
okay Sicilian Oh ADH okay so we do know
ADHD David
listing but there's only one D the duck
with the 500 bits
Thank You Ladakh appreciate the
generosity
doc the same duck that is in discord
there's someone in this Corps named duck
I think
there's also impatient duck who I played
yesterday maybe it's all the same person
anyway
I'm accepting this myth Maura just an
opening I like to
I actually enjoy this because I have
some prep
setup knight c6 and a6 and Queen c7
he's thinking which is a good sign
does Michael and Yuri still go to state
finals every year
I don't think Yuri was was there last
year or this past year
um Michael was though I think yeah Mike
was there we played pool after the
tournament
who won it I am so on it
pretty sure I'm still one it's Bishop f4
its new move
I was considering this but it might just
get destroyed by night b5
and how I'd be sad
just gonna play a six might be five is
just too scary and so many lines
a three giving me time now a complaint
97
plain ig6 with tempo
not too good in the Maura I haven't
played it in a while it's my coach's
favorite line though is coach Mark I
surfer him
Marquess Herman is like the Smith Mora
God
never never left I'm so so good
oh it's Jim fisting
I think I know Jim pretty sure I know
Jim
number ten seat is about to be the
number one seed
karissa and Sophie
wait really take a look at that game
but based on some of the games in the
juniors you can never be sure of a
result until the game is over so many
crazy things happen I just know that
based on my experience playing the
juniors so many topsy-turvy
rollercoaster games I'm going to take
the bishop
you
um play Bishop e7 or no let's play d5
first because if he takes I take back
with Bishop and if he doesn't take then
my pawns are happy
and I'm up upon
yeah I know Jim
not too well but I know Jeff
used to be a very strong chess team Oh
Unni and she helped coach Unni at some
point like a special guest lecture
I'll play Queen b6 because it just
improves the queen with tempo
disturb his his queen side
if he plays before I could maybe
consider my take before in the night
pinin win right
so what to see to after Bishop take
before
let's queen d4 then queen a5
doesn't work
whoa I forgot about my g5
well this makes a bead pawn a bit
irrelevant I have to play 98 here or
Queen c7 I'm gonna play 98
I think it's still okay
unless it's not okay
but if I have time to play each six
that should be okay
as he has queen a for a check but then I
played Bishop d7 think it's okay
Patrick b25 thanks Patrick for the
follow
you
low
sack the queen give away all your pieces
rawr etc
sounds like Ben Feingold
I'm fine gold say it's a sack sack the
queen
says rawr and he says etc
um okay I feel pretty comfortable here
you
I'm going to play h6 or I'll take the
pawn or I'll do both now I'll just play
h6
and then I'll complete development
they'll attack the night with tempo rip
Oh sip thanks for the follow
suspicious see who can name more been
fungal teens
to any been mangled sayings apply to
this position always retreats
wait now I want to play queen c6 though
yeah
both his mates are hanging squeen c64
retreating move it's more of a lateral
retreats always repeats and then always
retweet retweet retweet
there is some like great tweet by been
without retreating and retweeting
you know what it was
the truth hurts the tooth hurts
okay
I just have to always keep my 98 so I
don't run into trouble that's actually
pretty easy to do given my night can't
physically move I can try and drop it
somewhere but it can't move I can take
this night and I can take other nights
wait a minute
I take the other night he takes on g7
and then I play Bishop F fates
gates nc3 check
no I'm not going to do that
maybe six
because the night has so few squares and
wherever it moves I have Queen C 3
unless he plays that how I can't take
the night because he would make me
such a tricky person
play Bishop e7
now I'm threatening to take the night
this line is defended
and if the night moves I'll probably
have Queen c3
time situation is good I just got a
challenge from Elon Musk was this non
musk
also challenging the kramnik students
excise sparks
be careful not to get mated
the pawn will take on g7 I play this it
still takes a little bit of work to win
this and this is a past pond he'll
probably just push it until he Queens
you
that okay put the work on open file
what to do let's develop the night
I want to play King d7 King c7 and king
bee AIDS
because always flaking v8 rights or is
it always flaking d1 you both apply hey
I just want to find shelter there we go
sheltered what's the next step
safety shelter and loves rights have to
find mates
I just want to play rock g8d four and
move the night and then target g2
you
you
you
oh I thought he was gonna see Quincy
five
I'm just eating more food
now he's pawn storming let's play Queen
b3
I want to play this and then this and
then this
or just this
you
you
I have not been reading his comments not
really liking this move I've been
demoralized
it's one way of putting it
happens
I just want to play Knight b4
a strong move instructing the B file
Queen a3 so tricky he hopes that I take
care so he can take there well it's
probably still winning
but I can just take a queen
good try okay good game
ADHD David
uh who's the next victim oh thanks for
more follows Ivan
what is going on little Plotkin is
challenging me
thirty-four boomer with the sub Thank
You 34 boomer
um oh that was a previous opponents I
think his name is boomer 34 unless I'm
just having some hallucination
well I do appreciate that um some emotes
happening why can't I take on f4 I could
I could have taken on f4 but I was full
I wanted to meet him the point of night
before is finding Queen th3 because of
the Tim okay so now I'm gonna I'm going
to experience some pain because I'm
going to play a little Plotkin and my
score against little Plotkin is pretty
tragic
but what do I do let's find English
I'm only playing one game so win lose or
draw only one game good luck I have to
manage my time like this he's trying to
be tricky already I'm gonna be trickier
I'm in my prep a five is already a
slight in accuracy
trap here we'll see if he falls into it
he doesn't the trap is if Bishop c5 I
can take but now we have some position
we actually have a reverse time on earth
which is an opening that I like to play
as black
I'm just gonna develop our D Ardex 5150
thanks for the follow
I mean I'm in my comfort zone so it
can't be too bad
the typical idea here is to play nine a
four-night c5 or Knight e4 Knight c5 I'm
going to start with rook c1
there's other ideas of pressuring the C
file let's play 94 cuz I have ideas of
night g5 and night C 5
um King h8 was a good move because if I
play Knight g5 here's Bishop g8 so I
will play this and it's gonna get a bit
messy let's play E for my waiting upon
his might has to move and just take upon
unless he can take on e4 no time to
calculates thanks for the sub Ardex so
I'm up upon I can win another pond this
is a free pond looks like the free pond
and I have two bishops
but I'm playing a little clock and
nothing is safe when I play a little
clock in
I can take this okay it's officers call
your bishops this pawn is a little bit
weak my queen is sort of exposed and
like Queens tied on to the bishop
so what do I do I have to manage my time
there's insane music happening outside
I can play this
play Bishop e2 at some points or not
play Bishop III
you
a 5fu plays Rock 88
the good thing about being up to ponds
is that if you lose a pond you're still
up one pond
that made sense right
take your he's gonna do stuff like
Bishop e2 I don't think it does anything
though
you
okay let's play Queen here I'm defending
I'm attacking and I'm threatening me
than one
we will probably play Kimia cheats
you
or king h1 I'm just so focused on his
King
I have to watch out for attack though
because my pieces are perhaps not in the
best position
I can play this kick the rook away
Bishop e2 is going to be really annoying
don't play Bishop e2 please don't
to our key one
it's okay
this rook take III roped a key to
okay
I'm still up to pawns
upon time
you
I didn't see that but I have this that's
good
almost scary
okay now it's going to be a matter of
time which control the only open file
and let's put the Queen here
the Queen their queen here just gonna
keep putting my Queen places until he's
annoyed
and then I can take it can I take the
pond you can take the pond work age six
Queen f5
the man may be Queen d7 and Queen D to
defend
mmm that's really annoying because he
wins upon this is not what I wanted uh
I'm gonna just push my EEP on this is
not what I wanted
you
should be okay though still
free pawn
things up
you
like free pond there we go Queen trade
yes
okay should be easy with
you
I just don't want to mess this up there
you go okay
agree these
I'd be a little [ __ ]
I held my score 13 239 the last time I
played a little clock in one of the last
times I stalemated him having two
bishops against the king is painful
good game little talkin to wait until my
heart rate settles hey toilet noggin 100
bits things toilet noggin I mean to be
fair
what are these games some of these
schemes are our giveaway chess
people can't see this if I scroll down
zoom in see the ridiculousness of these
positions he's just so good a giveaway
chess or is it anti chess the game where
you give away all your pieces brain
Gaara
thanks for the sub
so many new subs preciate that what is
the sub counts
command for that
each AMC thanks for the follow okay I'll
play someone else odd is challenging me
um
play I'm debating I'll just play Lord on
in us
we haze and ends are they're too weak
too slow as emotes
subs nice
okay good luck Lord Lord an honest
is an honest is a pineapple like that
means pineapple in some language and on
us
was this what pineapple Lord
a little Potkin in the chat good game
you almost came back rated counterplay I
played b5 here in honor of Nathan Nathan
wanted me to play b5 earlier this
position b5 is a very playable move
Oh polish and pine okay so it's
pineapple in polis in Turkish and France
speak any of those languages
which I was thinking of
maybe maybe Indonesian
Apple in Indonesian
it's an indie - Wow
Oh
okay I'm gonna just play this one little
setup actually it's a slightly abnormal
seventh because idea is to play c5 you
don't see this every day just a matter
of gaining space on the queenside
and if he plays e4 it's kind of like a
closed Sicilian type position
really it's just the Kings Indian attack
b5 with a question mark says lemon chief
I would give p5 and exclamation points
um maybe it's slightly dubious but it's
been play that like GM level the idea is
if I ever plays a four black and
responding with b4 and restrict the
Knights
you
okay we have some position
and out of tea it's kind of sad
some more tea
after I move
see three
alright understand c3 just going to
castle
I guess one point of c3 is to play a
four and to try and discourage before
but I think I would play b4 anyway
in 92 is a fine move
lady five
if I play d5 we're transposing
yeah we're transposing into more like
mainline Kings Indian
stomper Reno asking is this my normal
stream time uh yes at least for this
week this is going to be my normal
stream time basically like 11 11 p.m. to
12 something a on prod time
until I get tired what kind of tea am i
drinking if anyone can translate this it
will see this
I don't know oh I had no idea it said
peppermint I was gonna ask to translate
Mata pledge it says peppermint okay
I knew it is some sort of mint
oh yeah that reminds me I'm gonna make
tea
okay looks like peppermints
I apologize for the background noise I
don't know if it's picking up but that's
the sound of tea
ah-6
take take efore I got the bishop pair
we also just play like a five
and I win Connect four
that's nice I just want to play b4 and
have it have it be supported by the ape
on
if I play d4 in Bishop a6 and he plays
efore d3 could be a target
and his tea sound of tea that's true
um miss Miyagi miss me I use back
come back miss Miyagi
can that eight and move one I guess
that's true
I mean
if I wanted to win Kinect eight
I would take
it takes some planning that would be
difficult maybe I can accomplish it well
I also want to play reasonable chess too
it'd be just what wing connect ate and
play good moves
and so had was Oh head
and final screw boat
how the worst-ever mean sense
vertically so you're asking me to get
quadruple pawns
that's difficult though there is a game
alexander alekhine with quadruple pawns
some crazy game on which he lost his
pawn structure was so bad and he was
down to pieces
Queen c2
okay I'm gonna play this because it's
time I think he has to take
LC wants to somehow drop back to e3 you
could draw back to f4
h5 and then Bishop e3
then I can start winning Connect AIDS
I think 9 h5 saw the best move
actually when the bishop comes to e3 I
think the idea of g5i five is is very
logical because I want to play f4 so
then I'll have it six pawns on the fifth
rank potentially
and then maybe I prepare this to play
just to reinforce f4
and then later I can open up the H file
with h5 for all finding a purpose
you
you
fans eonni is a queen of all openings
what's the king of all openings probably
be the London system
oh I forgot that was an option
completely forgot he could play Bishop
take Knights
maybe I take with Queen
want to prepare a five
and I still want to pawn store
he's probably going to play e4 and kill
all my fun
wertha shots
and there's no there's no increments
so
time is gonna be a factor yeah he's
killing all my fun
hmm
now I can't play you five losses upon
play Knight of 6 let's play Knight of 6
my knight has no purpose on h5 but it's
on this job I have the bishop here
I value the bishop Here I am giving him
more space
he's probably going to play d4 here
and then we have some like French
structure but I'm ready to store them on
the queenside
and my king is relatively safe
way before
if I need defense I could play rook ca
and neither favor bishop f8 it should be
good enough I have 15 pending challenges
I told people not to challenge me but
yesterday I had like 30 challenges so I
guess it's some improvements
mmm okay I'm gonna play rook c8
hey it's still possible I still have all
eight pawns I just have to get them all
to the fourth rank now as I've over
overextended the beep on
connect to I can get a pawn chain
the right strategy though I'm going to
start with Bishop a6 keeping all the
tension
kind of misconnect for it is a great
childhood game
about the diagonals position like this
if he ever lets me I don't know how he
could let me but if I can get my Bishop
to the outside of this pawn chain it's
just such it would be such a better
piece maybe I could have some plan like
Bishop b5 during my Queen to a6 and then
Bishop to e3
seems like he's playing without a plan
here
play Bishop c4 with
he plays b3
bishop play this
I think this is a reasonable plan
especially a PHY of time
you
you
okay Marty
she is my fuel
I don't think this is caffeinated though
I don't think peppermint has caffeine
does it
green tea has caffeine
a queen b7 he is c4 I don't have on
pissant maybe I'll play Queen a7 because
like his bishop on g2 its sneaky but it
could be relevant in some cases
Archer
how much tea have I drunk I usually have
two two cups a day with one morning one
evening you did play c4 anyway
interesting
complicated
and I probably have to take I'm
considering this tick-tick-tick
I take you could take with night and
then unleashes a bishop immediately
and if I take here I have to watch out
for my rook
but he doesn't have any immediate night
moves because I can take care so f take
take
I could take on d4
tacking his night he takes back I take
his night and should be good
maybe he'll play d5 that would be weird
you
miss Miyagi only drinks green tea let me
ask you do you drink green tea with
sugar or do you just drink it plain but
I've heard like sometimes people get
offended if it's if it's with sugar
uhh Hinault's you just you just saw my
YouTube video want to see if I'm
streaming a hey I'm streaming that's
great
I think that's one of the more popular
videos just because it's like it's so
controversial or at least the comments
for controversial but that's cool
you're not the first one to like be
watching a YouTube video and then just
joint which I think that happened a lot
yesterday
tt skirts things for the follow like I'm
gonna take care because I assume
I'm like I'm up upon and I'm attacking
as night and I can keep initiative
and I think this is all working out so
I'll play pani five
also I'm up a lot of time
yeah so I assumed something like this
would happen where he's getting maybe
I'll take with Queen
yeah he gets a rook for two miners but
now I have threats of 993
country is very hard to stop yes he
could take yeah please take my pond
ooh
what is this
Knight of three
jeetu
b7
should be good enough
I could play queen b7 immediately
okay this should be winning in many
cases I think I'll play Queen b7
immediately
it's funny but I think his queen is just
about trapped even though it's not
directly attacked but the rather of
neither three is so strong he can't move
his king anywhere so he has to move his
queen but where does this Queen go yes
yes f4 but then I'll play Knight f3
and just be winning somehow
so Queen not 4/9 I have a fork to here
you
but
to h3 its mates
so Knight f3 King G to Knight here here
and then mates problem is he has f3 so
now here here here f3
doesn't quite work
so maybe I have to double-check in
tonight okay I think I had this
i've night h4 and then queen g2 with
mating ideas
I serve 91
so indecisive let's do this
him before he flags yes okay good game
Lord Lord pineapples
yeah thank you
and Gigi
um what happened in that game that game
got a bit silly that was I was trying to
win connect eights toilet not again
without another hundred bits
thanks toilet noggin yeah I think the
complications just all went in blacks
favor but maybe it was already difficult
sometimes these structure is white
should go for like h4 night 1 h2 Knight
g4 and then someday sac on h6
um but it takes a long time and I have
defensive resources
so yeah I don't know I will say that
also a four can be an effective move
because in many cases like you get
control over the c-4 square
never put sugar sugar is bad the place
I'm saying does not have sugar so I
guess I'm in luck
okay I'm going to move on
why not playing by about three
immediately
I could have played Knight f3
immediately I just wanted to play Queen
d7 this is actually a moment it's good
kind of instruction of instructive
instructional instructive moment
triplets when you're debating between
Knight f3 and Queen b7
um queen b7 is a type of move that will
make your opponent think more because if
I plain out of three the move is forced
but it's it's more forcing if I play
Queen b7 it's far less forcing here's
more options and that's good when your
opponent I'm not sure
um do not wait how do i bow no comment
someone just shared a link which is a
bad link
I'm sorry but I'm gonna time you out
just because HS calm is like a malware
site this doesn't mean you're banned
you're just timed out if you want to
share leech s org you can do so when
you're not time to act
please stop sharing the link
okay um we're gonna move on and let's
play someone else let's play excise
sparks he deserves it for being a mod
you
oh yeah I guess you can remove a tie now
you just tie them out and then remove it
axé villager if you can prevent people
from sharing links I don't know if night
night night BOTS can do that um that
would be nice
good luck have fun
what am i playing let's play Knight f3
player ready
thousand bits for roy lopez exchange
well that's hard to do because i played
nine f3 um i would say if he played the
five I would play e4 to try and get the
right Lopez
do I do here c4 let's play c4 son
sort of position
forget what I played in the
past play g3 just place some kind of
this is a bit slower
this line has been very popular in the
Junior Championship I've seen a lot of
people playing this I think Maggie fain
was playing this and
I think Carissa played this at some
point
the idea is to get some like reverse
banco or reverse Benoni
he's leaving the tension not a bad idea
I guess I could take on d5 and if it
takes back with pom I play d4 and give
him an some kind of IQ pee
hello Hulbert hf it's another streamer
good to see you
let's take
and this chat chad has turned into code
talk JavaScript PHP okay let's focus on
the game
Bishop e7 I think this is still some
sort of main line like tirage
it can play Knight c3 here
and then someday Bishop g5 as far as I
know the positions are pleasant for
whites
just because d5 is a long-term target
you
I don't really know too much
but too many specific like exact lines
okay this makes me happy is he can't
attack the Queen immediately unless he
hates Queen b6 but now okay this pawn is
a massive liability for black he has to
play Bishop u6 I'll play rook d1
and I have four attackers
you
oh I'll be throw-in Bishop g5 because
why not
I Bishop g5 you could play h6 and then a
high-tech he attacks the Queen and then
place d4 so maybe I'll just try and win
the pawn or quickly
you
it's difficult position is he can't
defend the pawn he's probably best off
castling
be six
not
my first instinct is to take
taken and take but then he has some work
to get ideas
would probably take first and then rook
to use but then I have a four
that looks good
yeah II four should be
you
should be enough to give me some simple
advantage if I didn't have you for it
could get very bad rook t8 immediately I
think just makes life very very nice for
whites so you forgot about 97
King FA this forests
now I can take on da take on u6 take on
b7 I'll be up to pawns
I'll have the bishop pair
and yeah this is this is nice
I kind of forgot about taking opening
recommendations someone saying Kings
gambit excellent riblets
Grob earlier angry centipede asking if I
do chest classes I do give like private
instruction I have a Lee chest coaching
profile de shins yo says hey hello
ditions vo
open file
super Salian
sloth or caro-kann do my best
he wants to play Knight g4 which is kind
of annoying I'm gonna play Bishop f3
restricting the Knights now I just want
to play a 3 B 4
this filter works now Thank You X
villager
if you want oh he's cuz thinking before
pinning and winning but then he takes on
f - oh that actually works was my rook
is defended
yeah that's nice
at a premium King take f2 or uptick see
it I will be king take after
okay he's trying to complicate things
I can just move the bishop Bishop g5
I'll play e4 okay I'm not gonna
overthink this
we'll be simple I would hope he really
wants me to remove my bishop so you can
take on f2
but I can play Bishop III now I'm
winning an exchange
and I'll still be up to pawns
miss Miyagi thank you for the comment
miss Miyagi deeper than anyone I don't
know if I can see deeper than anyone I
do like to try and explain myself
wowyou keeps counter-attacking
but I can do this
at some point it'll just run out of
counter-attacks
I think now he has to take on you three
you
you
or this witch
bishop
two pawns
just want to win cleanly gonna play a
four
if I take on c5 he had Brooke d2 which
was kind of annoying and this is a
strong passed pawn play rook 8:1 and
just keep pushing the pawn he's going to
try and get counter play with the bishop
on d4
Bunji for is nice this night is tied
down to the pond but any point I can
take the Nightwind the pond
also just push my pond
I just want some position where I don't
have to think
just push pawns and drink tea
although mod blocked a message for
profanity but it's just it's just a
message with big words
computability theory and artificial
intelligence research allowing that
comments okay I'm gonna push pawn still
he's going to try and play c3
but white is winning the race
I'll take the Knights
you
you
you
any Merson
and in this
now positions where you don't have to
think are grades that's why I enjoy
studying openings its if you're like
playing an opening you know you don't
really have to think it's recite moves
okay good game exercise sparks oh what's
the appropriate message thank you okay
what did X I sparks do wrong I think he
just went into an opening or some
structure he wasn't familiar with
allowing this iqp structure wasn't the
most pleasant thing for a black
normally black should just castle I
would think it's the theory here
because yeah this is a popular position
castling button masters database this
has been played before i GMS
um I was gonna play Bishop g5 in h6
Bishop III is already already feels
awkward cuz Knight g4 but maybe it's
playable Oh Knight g4 I can take on d5
4x I sparks I can recommend if you face
this line d4 perfectly fine move you get
like a reverse Benoni type position
what else can I recommend I can also
recommend taking this is actually a
simple line so just include in like your
repertory where usually at some point
white plays Queen a4 check and then
I play this as black I like to play C 6
and then B 5 Queen drops back Bishop e7
and you get some setup
I played something similar earlier came
from like a semi Slav
but it came from a semi sloth because
x-eye sparks recommended the semi sloth
and this is kind of like a semi-soft
like setup anyway good game I'll move on
play someone else 17 pending challenges
to play the ultra bullet guy cuz we'll
get this over with quickly de viateur
ultra bullet good luck cream of d5
Bishop g4 maybe
oh my gosh I'm so slow let's made him on
the h-file oh I dropped a queen
Luke's oh my gosh this is so low-quality
chess
this is so low-quality
my computer's lagging no I flagged I was
up a rook
about to be a crook oh that was too
laggy good game
Davey either ultra that's my first loss
of this stream so sad
eat some more tissue okay well let's not
do that again
let's play kramnik students because I
think he was challenging me yesterday
and it's an interesting name and I'm
white yes let's wait for
if he's kramnik student I was about to
say he's gonna play e5 but okay that's
not the case it's play Knight c3
from India
play a close Sicilian usually I play
Grand Prix attack but this time I mean
I'm gonna be slow
10 plus 5
you
you
six okay
normally people play g6 Bishop g7 and
then there's very clear ideas with East
six
to figure out what's the best set up for
light I could play f4 and 903
I could play 92
I'm guessing he's he wants to play d5 at
some point
let's start with 92
I just want to castle
maybe at some point play like f4 h3g for
how he plays d5
okay let's play
aah 3
okay let's play ch3
I'm keeping all the tension there's
future ideas of g4 93
curious to see if will relieve the
tension in any way which he does
the
wasting a little bit of time moving this
night
because it's a closed position
you
to redevelop apply f4 here
we have some kind of like Kings Indian
structure now
I for is a thematic idea it's also very
thematic to bring the knight to c4 and
play a four restricting b5
okay we'll see what happens
axe villager having internet problems by
ox villager
be healthy
I like ice cream too I will admit his
fame is great
but you need it in the portions
reasonable proportions
okay
I have a bunch of options I can dig with
ninth Bishop or pawn or rook
you
I think with Bishop here's 9 h5 which is
a bit annoying
Nick with Knights stick with Knights
usually in like these kings in the
instructors a bishop is completely okay
staying back for a while because it does
its job on this diagonal
I mean chief would take with rook so
it's easier to sack rooks don't normally
like to be on central squares so early
on because they're targets and you
should value them you should not just
sack them
okay I bring my knight back into the
game
I have two ideas I've night c4 or Knight
f3 I'll probably play Knight f3 the
focus should be on the kingside I'm
gonna start with a four though
restricting b5 is a six which is very
normal
[Music]
if I had two moves to play like Knight C
4 and a 5 that would be nice
I don't have two moves
funny line here 94 b5 take take a five
take
and I take and I win a piece it's real
life
for here I just play e5 immediately
you
I'm so tempted
night c4b v e5 I hope he's not watching
this is a top-secret plan
take take
it's risky
is 98 I'd see for b5e 598 Bishop takes
c6 I should throw in 885 they take b5
Bishop takes c6 you take C for D takes
c4 ie pawns overextended be files open
this doesn't look good it's just a trade
complete g4
like Queenie one greenie one's tricky
and the play Queen e1
you
I considered 21 like five seconds before
moving is usually not the correct
approach to thought process
but maybe I just completely forgot he
could play this move I probably have to
move back
oh that's okay that's life
close positions are the worst yeah this
could be a longer game which I apologize
to all the people waiting
nice to see there's fewer challenges in
yesterday
you
one has to live longer to give up things
that are worth living for
mmm yes or no you just have to enjoy
healthy things
play queen here
you
okay so we get some musician
you
I really have made
progress so fast three moves Queenie one
Queen D one
I could play g4 I could still go for
this minus three idea
you
I play chief or am i threatening
five
maybe
maybe not
I'm gonna start with Knight of three
this is the only logical square for the
Knights
everything else so just decide later
kind of play g4
you
is
you
maybe play Bishop d2 and do some
manoeuvring
actually don't mind the position
I've used a lot of time though just
calculating nonsense but the position
itself is fine
g5 could be a threat if I play G 597 h4
I'm just gaming space
you
thing for him I don't quite know what
he's up to
maybe he wants to
not gonna say anything cuz I have a
feeling he might be watching and I just
don't want to give him ideas rook a it's
a move it's a good move
50 to take take I lose a seat on
so I probably have to take
let's give him the e-file
not ideal but now Bishop d2 I probably
want to take on before next and maybe I
could play Queen anyone if he drops back
yeah I always have to assume my plan is
watching
his reading this rapid bullet
need to turn this into a bullet game
all triplets
you
well because this queen is no longer on
g8 g5
this appears to be more attractive
but I'll know how to execute that strong
of the King side attack like g5 and then
what
maybe I can somehow maneuver my night to
five I could
run into tactics so for example knight
c6 Knight h4 you could take and attack
this but maybe I do this anyway
9h for
candidate move 9h for night a key for
905
times you have to navigate through the
tactics so you can play good positional
chess
my niche for g5 I of 9f5 so that's not a
problem
this is a type of position I want in I
have an i-5 so my H for an ATV for now
the five is bishops hanging with check
doesn't really have any counter
attacking bishop moves and his mind is
hanging you take on d2 I take on u7 it's
just a trade though
wait for is it
here your takes I take he plays there I
take I'm up a minor piece this is
defended I can always move back let's go
for an ith for
you
you
lots of comments that I'm missing Eric
you are the best thank you lash at Jane
miss Miyagi confirms chess God thank you
miss Miyagi people in the chat are so
nice
okay
Patrick who is this Patrick his name is
so light green
Stream makes it more enjoyable that's
good to hear Patrick if you guys have
feedback let me know things yet you want
to see more of different types of things
that you want to see
I've miss Miyagi I mentioned briefly
that g5 runs into 95 and I
counter-attack the bishop which is a
benefit in a lot of these lines because
Bishop is attacked with Czech g6 is a
useful move because it restricts both my
Knights
I have to think
still kind of wanna play
five
I could go absolutely crazy and plane
out of five
let's calculate g5 this is my house to
retreat he goes back
and then I could go crazy
at some point I'm probably just going to
go crazy
five take
five
keep in mind he's watching all of this
looks reasonable or unreasonable but it
looks fun
now he'll think
is probably going to be a factor pretty
soon the good thing for white is I have
like all my pieces directed at the
kingside
kathas of his pieces are doing nothing
on the queenside
so if I suck at peace I'll still have
more attackers and he has defenders
rights
now maybe that's still about a decision
this thinking my rook is so happy
and he'll think more which is good
Rosen Crecy what what would that be
it's a do a photo shoot for that was 17
c3 any good
I'll check briefly 17 c3 I considered it
briefly but I think it just loses upon
because d3 hangs maybe I'm wrong but
pretty sure I'm right
that's good he's thinking here he's
hesitant to take he doesn't take I have
nine of six ideas
see for
whirring everything does he even have a
threat I don't think he has a threat by
just I'm defending this maybe he wants
to play this or this or this plane out
of six
or I could play 9f5 and just continue to
be crazy
much time I'm gonna play night of six
maybe someday I'll play another five
you
c4 is explosive
it is true
you
I'm finally up on time hasn't happened
for a while
I've been checking
notifications
you to the new followers though thank
you odd your roof's key owner I'm 99
solid Mickey 21 to Shinzo Amburgey
appreciate the follows
he's like some next-level sex I mean I'm
just
they're good sacks but at least they're
making him think and take right the pond
and now I just want to gather Queen to
g7
only this word bughouse
maybe not a five here knife five rights
just look at all those pieces they're
all on the queenside
my pieces are all if I can draw arrows
they're all doing stuff on the kingside
especially this bishop
so now the idea is if he takes
actually I'm not going to share that
idea because he might be watching but if
he wants to know the idea he can take
the night's so had one thanks for the
follow
Gabriel Thomas Newton
when they watch me live so I'm assuming
a lot of people have just come from
YouTube is that the case
it feels like a lot of people like they
they watched the YouTube like stream
archives and then they they click the
link and then they see I'm live which is
cool
the Cutrone yes say knife I fight I
thought I was a final quote
anyway I'm suffering from allergies I
have more time than him c3 is
interesting because I take he takes back
with Czech
I would like to do more stuff on the the
Kings side
what to do
I have a funny idea I'm gonna play
Bishop h6 an attackers rook also saving
my bishop which I didn't realize but I
guess that's a useful purpose another
follow from Lucas 7 and now I think I
want to play Bishop g7
right Bishop g7 and now I have a threats
ooh he prevented the
I thought he was going to take the night
I was threatening that eh6 meat so he
creates lift for the king
now I can play 96 and when a seven and
this should be this should be winning
you
I tried sacking both my Knights you
didn't take either of them and now I'm
up upon
five is coming
followed by f7 is no way to the fens e5
just kind of sad for him
is it lagging again its lagging again
I'm sorry if it's lagging again I don't
know what causes that Ryan like close
tabs
um
if I play Knight g5 kingi AIDS let's try
and just win smoothie
is there a queen sac could take on h5
that just loses a queen
no I can wait a minute by g5 King g8
f7 King to g7
then I take the rook and rook f7 and I
can take on b7 oh I'm I'm up a lot of
material and that'sa in that position
blue 8c thanks for the follow
I just see the chat rook f5 I did not
consider a wreck I thought maybe it was
a good move
more exciting finishes but this is good
enough
two different types of pieces we promote
to a night right
and then do this
you
this after watch out for his pawn
I'll be up a rook
enough
who he takes
takes on b2 while okay so this is a
potential queen but this is an actual
queen
see threatening he's not threatening
anything I can play Knight here as he
was trying to take the Knights but any
time I can win the pawn
maybe he'll play Bishop a3 but then I'll
I'll still have 96
when does he resign never
far
he's not resigning I mean he has a pawn
on me too I can't blame him I wouldn't
resign in this position either if I were
black but maybe in the hood resign oh
wait a minute Queen I for this is not to
write in Queen that faith because bishop
moves Bishop can move backwards
if you guys still play Queen iPhone
though
still play queen f1 I think I have some
sneaky threats
you
yeah I'm more focused on mates than
winning puns
Oh chronic students in the chat traffic
students oh he's winning
if he was kramnik maybe he would be
winning
anok student
he5 you
defender seven
so head sank in g5
kingi five would be difficult
okay I have eleven pending challenges
some people are so patient
I'm sorry alpha zero wizard I just don't
accept casual or I don't accept
respondents
where's my mates h4
tor is a vice position on
reinforcing the night
we purse a lien not on the list
Daniel Moreno
I can play them in ages five card draw
thanks for the follow
we're now seven is very hard to stop
there's two ways to stop it with three
ways to stop it can i still play Queen
f7 allow him to Queen
that gets messy though King Bishop f1
might be doable Queen a 7 Queen Bishop
f1
just want to be extra sure that should
work
you
if I played King h2 here without Bishop
g6 and I think that would be tragic that
would just be like made into for him
or made them three okay so busy
you
Wow
they'll have taken on d4 when I have it
I miss may than to wear is made into
missing I do accept ultra bullet miss
Miyagi I'll fight ultra bullets feel
free
I mean Queen age seven meters of threats
so okay good game chronic students
um didn't quite play like Kramnik that
wasn't interesting in was some nice
attacking build-up this is actually a
pretty common structure resulting from
closed Sicilian or black commits to d4
and then like goes bananas
Queenie one was careless I was happy
with my h4 it took some work ID to
calculate stuff but it was a fun game
okay um I'll look at the challenges I'm
really suffering now because of
allergies I think I'm gonna end it here
it's after 1:00 a.m. in Prague thank you
everyone for watching
miss Miyagi wanna play ultra bullets I
would finish with an ultra bullet game
but no I'm gonna end it here thanks guys
for watching go to the homepage uh maybe
I can raid this person stay around if
you want to join the raid
but I will take off and see you guys in
the future bye